Hi everybody. Welcome. We are going to
be talking about so much tonight. And if
you're
around just today,
man, we're in the middle of so much with
the Epstein files and all that's going
on politically and in the world. And I'm
actually really excited because
these are things that God showed me in
2020 and he opened my eyes to all of it
that every politician, every athlete,
every president and every
celebrity is in on. And unfortunately, I
do know that it's in every church as
well. Satan has infiltrated it whether
by Jesuits and Freemasons or Satan
worshippers and witches or
pastors have given in and been bribed or
paid off or whatever it might have been.
They have been sold out.
So we really have to understand that the
world itself is being overcome and
probably has been for so much time. It
has been satanic
and that is what truth is being brought
out that if you are anyone who has been
in leadership and is in leadership you
have had to do the things which are
mentioned in the Epstein files
and tonight
particularly we have seen and we're
going to see in different ways how the
church has actually given in to certain
winds of doctrine certain things that
have swayed them that They are not a
true church of God, but an occult one
following after occult things.
But when I've seen, and I'm excited
particularly because when you know the
truth, the truth sets you free. And I've
seen so many people, there's too many
Christians who are always asking about
things. What do you think about this?
Want they want to debate it. They want
to argue different things going on in
the world because they are seriously
they've been dismayed. And God says, "I
do not be dismayed by the things of this
world." Why? Because I've seen you guys
run after everything in the world that's
been propaganda or church news or gossip
or the things of celebrities and other
church pastors. And I want
everyone to come to finally, and I think
they are finally able to take a chance
at looking at the world now for what it
is and not being dismayed. Stop putting
your extra time and effort and brain and
energy and power into trying to research
these things. Stop.
It is what it is. And you are to be a
light in this world to stand true for
God.
And these are the particular things
which I have seen people they're not
they're just fighting with each other
picking fights with others. they are
just being a part of the propaganda
being spread and the this kind of raging
that's going on. And so finally you guys
can just keep your focus ahead on Jesus
leading you and realizing that in
following him
a lot of people have been following in
falling into the booby traps along the
side in the dark places on the sides of
the roads of the narrow path. They
haven't been keeping their eyes on
Jesus. And
man, that is what I want you guys to
know now especially is a time to rise up
and to know understand fully
what the world is for what it is and to
stand true for Christ. Now let's look at
this because I had this is all prompted
this particular topic is prompted by a
viewer who with a genuine heart wanted
to know
how do I know that I am in the true
church that's following Christ and we
all should be asking that question we
should all be gathering ourselves now in
the time of chaos and going I want to be
one of God's people so let's take a look
at this let's jump fully And
I'm calling this dead giveaways. You're
in an oult church. By the time we get
through this, I don't think you will uh
think this is an exaggeration
because the world truly is. It's going
towards you either either worship Satan
or you worship God.
So let's look at the first thing. The
first thing we will notice is baptism. A
clue is if they are sprinkling. if they
do sprinkling baptisms.
Um it doesn't matter if it's human um
adults or babies.
The truth of the matter is
that sprinkling with holy water as a
form of baptism is not a biblical
practice, but rather a pagan ritual that
traces back to the worship of Deeon, the
ancient Philistine fish god. Deeon
priests wore fish-shaped miter hats and
performed water rituals as symbolic acts
of fertility and purification
which were later absorbed into Roman
Catholic tradition instead of biblical
full body immersion
used throughout the New Testament to
represent death, burial, and
resurrection in Christ into new life. I
may add,
sprinkling became a convenient religious
substitute, stripping baptism of its
true meaning. This practice was adopted
by the early church through synretatism
as Rome blended all pagan excuse me all
pagan customs into Christian liturgy
into the Christian
doctrine
replacing the command to repent and be
fully immersed with a lifeless tradition
of droplets and ceremony. It's a
counterfeit symbol of rebirth with no
biblical foundation.
This is the god Deeon that they just
spoke about. He kind of has like a
paintbrush in his hand and that is a
bucket of water he keeps using to
sprinkle.
That's where it comes from. All right,
the next one is holidays. I don't care
what holiday it is. Um, a clue is that
the church celebrates any of these
holidays. Specifically,
um, ones that are common are Christmas,
Easter, Halloween, or harvest festivals,
etc. Like I said, any of them.
Here's a depiction. I know a lot of
people like to debate to do holidays or
not, but the truth is none of them are
Christian.
Christmas is really Satanelia or Ule,
the birth of Tamuz, not Jesus. Easter
really stands for Ishtar and other
goddesses that have come down through
mythology. Fertility goddess worship. In
other words, Halloween is
um I forget how you say that. Sam Hayne,
sin. There you go. Sin, a druidic death
celebration.
And the Bible says in Jeremiah 10 2
through3, learn not the way of the
heathen.
and why it's not of God specifically.
These celebrations are not harmless fun,
but have deep occult roots involving
witchcraft, necromancy, and sexual
ritual.
If your church does these things, it is
not a church of God, but a temple of
blended paganism,
pure and simple. The second one is the
way they decorate.
That can be anywhere from the tapestries
to really how they actually decorate the
church. But a clue is the church
displays include crucifixes, Jesus
portraits in more of like a Catholic um
way, crowns with a cross inside and
keys, angels in kind of demonic
even babyike ways, and especially
statues of Mary and the supposed saints
or apostles. and IHS inscriptions.
IHS is often seen engraved on altars or
sacred objects. It is said to represent
the name of Jesus, but it really has
roots in ancient sun worship and was
adopted by the Jesuits.
It subtly signals to the mysterious a
mystery religion of Babylon,
specifically here of Egypt. IHS is
correlated with Egypt embedding
symbolism tied to ancient triads and
hidden doctrines. Why is it Egypt?
Because it's Isis Horus set or um
yeah set. Okay. So it subtly reinforces
theological systems which are a textbook
marker of the counterfeit trinity that
mirror pagan god family structures with
father, mother and child rather than
clearly revealing Christian spiritual
truth.
Okay? And um recently we went to a
church where this was outrightly put
everywhere. And this is what you will
find. If you've not seen my
if you have not seen my coverage of
Freemasonry exposed, please go look at
that because it covers more of this in
depth. Symbols like we're looking at
here, the pentagram,
the symbols within it, the cup, the
dagger, I don't know if you can see that
the compass and square, and then the G
with the square and compass outrightly
for Freemasonry is not Christian. None
of these things can be melded with
Christianity. This is satanic worship.
This is secret societies which means it
is Satan worshippers
symbols. This what that's what
Freemasons and Jesuits are.
And um further than that you will find
specifically this symbol IHS
which I said um stands for the trinity
the false trinity and it is everywhere
in this picture. A lot of churches they
do they have so much symbolism that
again if you want to know more about
symbolism please go look at my
Freemasonry one. It explains so much
more of it.
All right. The truth is that the second
commandment forbids all graven images
bowing lighting candles or even visually
revering these objects is idolatry. It
says in Exodus 20 4-5,
"You shall not make for yourselves any
graven image."
These items operate as focal points of
worship and often carry spiritual power
from demonic sources. That is what I
want you to know. It is not of God is
not the Holy Spirit. It's claimed
battleground for Satan.
Okay? This also goes for architecture.
Look around. The clue is large buildings
with steeples, domes, columns, and
ornate altars. There's several other
things, but steeples equal obelisks or
the phallic symbol for bail worship.
Domes are wombs of the goddess who have
been impregnated. Many were designed
with Masonic and pagan geometry. And it
says in Deuteronomy 7 26, "Neither shall
you bring an abomination into thine
house, lest thou be a cursed thing like
it."
So here's a picture. Of course, we have
the Washington Monument. We have it in
Egyptian obelisk worship um and church
steeples. It never should have been a
thing we
melded into our life. But these
structures and images are not
spiritually neutral. They are part of
Satan's architectural and symbolic
playbook. Intentionally designed to
invoke ancient pagan worship and grant
spiritual legal ground.
steeples, domes, altars, and embedded
symbols function as claims of ownership.
Like I said, it Satan is putting his
mark of ownership on that church. Much
like contracts, giving demonic powers
jurisdiction over the building and
influence over those who gather within
it. God never commanded monuments
built on pagan geometry like the
Freemasons. He desires living temples
submitted to him, not structures
consecrated through occult symbolism.
Also, the day the clue is if the church
gathers on Sunday, calls it the Sabbath,
and treats it as sacred.
I'm just going to say it
straightforwardly.
God sanctified the seventh day, which is
on our calendar. Before it had a name,
it was just the seventh day. Then as the
Romans came along and they gave it a
name, it became Saturday or Saturday.
Just because it became that known as
that does not mean it is associated with
any pagan thing
when God
designed it to be the day that he wanted
us to keep.
That means that if the seventh day was
sanctified by God, it wasn't the first
day which is Sunday.
Sunday is the day of the sun god
enforced by Constantine in 3:21 AD to
unite pagans and Christians kind of
under falsehood.
Exodus 20:10 says, "The seventh day is a
Sabbath of Jehovah your God."
Why is this not of God fully? Because
you are obeying man's tradition over
God's command. Basically, Rome created
this command to go out to all other
empires and kingdoms. That is also why
every kingdom and empire goes to kiss
the ring of the pope and still get his
approval to this day. And when you will
obey man's tradition over God's
commands, it is rebellion. And the Bible
calls rebellion witchcraft.
Sunday sanctification is rooted in sun
worship, not scripture.
You will not find it anywhere in
scripture.
This is actually a um a post
that says the papacy freely admits to
changing the seventh day of rest to
Sunday. And it does so because as it
quotes below, the Catholic record
written September 1st, 1923
actually comes from one of their
writings, official writings, and it says
the Catholic Church is above the Bible.
And this transference of the Sabbath
observance is proof of that fact. They
claim this staunchly. They are very
proud of it. um that they changed God's
Sabbath from the seventh day for the
whole world to Sunday.
Music. The clue is that worship music
involves repeated phrases, dark rooms,
fog machines, and emotional highs.
This is not really what resembles a
church, but usually what you'll find
within satanic
temples when they do their rituals.
This is not biblical worship at all.
It's transinduction
used in Hinduism, new age rituals, and
sorcery to alter consciousness through
frequency
and fine-tuned by the Bethl elevation
and hill song music creators.
Why it's not of God is because it is
manipulating your mood with music. It is
not holy spirit-led. It creates false
fire or a false sense of worship and
getting something out of it,
but it leaves people addicted to emotion
because of that, not anchored in truth.
The next is tongues. The clue is that
people are babbling in gibberish without
interpretation, flailing or laughing,
calling it tongues.
The truth is that biblical tongues are
real languages understood by others in
Acts 2.
But uninterpreted nonsensical tongues
are condundalini manifestations or let's
just call it what it is, demon
manifestations.
It says in 1 Corinthians 14:22
and 9, I believe. Let's flip that.
Corinthians 14:19-22,
I believe. It says, "Tongues are for a
sign. Yet in the church, I would rather
speak five words with my understanding
that I may teach others also than 10,000
words in an unknown language." So it's
saying it has to be a
known language
to the world but
with without knowing if it were
if you didn't have understanding of the
language that existed in the world.
Paul who I think is writing this is
saying I would rather speak five words
with my understanding
that would actually further their
understanding to teach them than 10,000
words in an unknown language. So he
would never want to do that.
All right. So we have an example of
Paula White who was openly doing
speaking in tongues and gibberish and
the Bible verse in Acts 2 11 that says
we hear them speaking in our own tongues
the wonderful works of God. So that
means it was real languages that the
disciples and apostles were given the
ability to speak. Although they didn't
have previous knowledge of it, they were
given the ability to speak other
languages to reach each person in their
own tongue to understand the gospel of
Christ. That is the good news. That's
great.
But we also have examples, and I didn't
want to really include this, but witches
speak in tongues. They have light
languages. is in fact kind of along the
same lines as the Epstein files right
now. certain news is coming out about
the uh cannibal club
and the cannibal club had that model
that escaped from it. And um what they
found was that they had several
prestigious people who were
there of course but the entertainment
the lady that was hired for being the
entertainer
was speaking in tongues. She was there
and she is known for speaking in
tongues.
So you have to really be careful.
All right. The full truth is if what is
spoken is not a real known language
given by God to reach and edify others
for the gospel that you didn't
previously know already, then it is not
the Holy Spirit at work. The Holy Spirit
brings clarity, understanding, and
edification always.
Always, you guys. Gibberish that
produces confusion points instead to a
counterfeit spirit and not the spirit of
God.
All right. The next is a message clues
like phrases that are being used like
decree and declare speak your destiny
command your harvest or prosperity
gospel and the and to manifest.
These are all ungodly. The truth is that
this is not prayer prophecy. It's
actually verbal spellcasting. And I mean
that you guys. It is verbal spellcasting
drawn from the law of attraction and
witchcraft principles
directly. In Matthew 5:37,
it says, "Let your yes be yes." And I
had to shorten it, but and your no be
no. Anything more is from evil.
Okay. You have examples like Joel
Ostein, um, Copeland, I don't know the
other guy, Benny Hinn, and you have also
Andy Stanley. All right, these are only
a few examples, but they're all out
there. Pretty much most of them are of
that type. They are false. They're all
preaching these things. Why this is bad
is because God is not a force to
manipulate with affirmations. He
responds to obedience and faith, not
word magic and chance said with
positivity.
You cannot mix witchcraft with worship
of God, the true God. God is not your
vending machine and declar and de
declaration theology is new age sorcery
dressed in a suit
a suit of holiness I might add this
includes sermons that revolve around
your calling your elevation your
prosperity or finding the power within
yourself
this is rebirth and remaking of yourself
into your own god
but Jesus preached repentance
righteousness and self-deny denial. If
you leave every service feeling hyped
about yourself, something must be wrong.
He is supposed to be your peace, your
reassurance, and your savior, not you
being that for yourself. Worship of self
is also a root of satanic worship to
become your own god.
It says, "Deny yourself, take up your
cross and follow me," says Christ in
Luke 9 verse 23.
The true gospel confronts sin.
Narcissistic preaching fuels the flesh
and not the spirit.
We've got enough of that going on today.
The next is worshiping titles. Now, a
lot of leaders in your church, this is a
clue, will demand to be called apostle
this or that, prophet this or that, or
bishop, and go unchallenged
or to be always addressed as pastor,
father or minister.
This can go both ways. As I've seen, I
have really come to the fact that um
actually, let's go back. Let's read this
verse real quick before I get into that.
So the truth is that Jesus warned
against the hierarch hierarchical
systems. Titles often replace fruit and
truth.
It says in Matthew 23 3:8, "Call no man
rabbi, for you are all brothers." All
right? So in other words, you guys are
all equal. You are man. You are faulty.
You are mankind.
No one is above you.
And I except for God, we should really
take that into account. And what I was
going to say about this is I have had
people
tell me for the most part that that
because someone is a pastor,
um
that I cannot speak
ill of them, if they are openly doing
something wrong, I can't say anything
about what they're doing. That is not
truth. That's manipulation of title. And
I personally like to call people on
their first name um by their first name
because I want to keep things equal and
accountable.
And I think that's something we need to
do because it's not really we shouldn't
be giving them privilege based on their
credentials to act as though they're
holier than you and that they know
everything. Some people don't even
question what's being fed to them ever.
And
we need to be careful.
So,
let's go back to the slide. It says,
"Why it's not of God?" Well, these
systems mirror Babylonian priesthoods
that elevate man and silence the spirit.
They create spiritual eliteism and allow
a door into false rituals, teachings and
ideologies. For those trying to posture.
So those who are bringing in false
rituals, teachings and ideologies, they
are using their title
as a protective mechanism
usually with pride attached. So they
protect themselves from responsibility
while they sneak error into the church.
Think about it. clergy and robes is the
same as Egyptian priesthood in all of
history.
Process processions are pagan pageantry.
Cathedrals are based on solar geometry
and lay lines and stained glass saints
are icons of idolatry.
They've never changed
unity.
Well, if your church
from the pulpit promotes interfaith
events partnering with the Catholics,
Muslims or universalists
or I might add most any other
denomination.
It is preaching ecumenicism which is
unity at all costs. This is compromise.
The truth is that real unity is based on
truth and truth alone. The truth of the
Bible, not compromise. The push for
global religious unity is paving the way
for the one world religion known as the
new world order to all other people.
It says in the Bible, "What fellowship
has light with darkness?" 2 Corinthians
6:14.
And it's true. This is like a picture of
every type of denomination, even African
and Catholic. And you have Cabalis
there. You got Jews there. You've got
the Pope. Everyone
looks like you got a Satanist in that
corner over there on the right.
And um they're all coming together again
to
let's say stop the facade of being
different and coming together as one
finally. And that's what they're looking
forward to fully. But you know,
anyway, that's what your church is is
already doing and already has been doing
if they preach this. And they will be in
line to submit when the full order goes
out for
um complete ecumenicism
to be rolled out. Why it's not of God?
Because truth should actually divide.
God did come
to divide.
Ecumenicism creates a lukewarm powerless
church that blends with Babylon and
paganism and will not be known to God.
This is proof because in Matthew 7:22-23
it says, "Many will say to me in that
day, Lord, Lord, have we not prophesied
in thy name and in thy name have cast
out devils and in your name done many
wonderful works?" And then will I
profess unto them, I never knew you.
Depart from me, ye that work iniquity.
It's so true. The next one is LGBTQ plus
affirmation.
Clues of course would be rainbow flags,
pride month sermons or inclusive
language from the pulpit.
Blending male and female type of
ideologies is actually baffit doctrine,
a cult inversion of the divine order.
It says in Leviticus 18-22, "Thou shalt
not lie with mankind as with womankind."
It is an abomination. It goes on to
explain in the Bible in Leviticus as
well that that includes children,
animals,
your mother, your father, anybody
basically.
If they're not your wife,
and it's a male and female relationship,
it is an abomination before the Lord.
And it's not of God because these are
rituals and perversions of Satan's
rebellion, not love.
Ancient fertility temples practiced
same-sex rights as worship of false gods
and is an initiation ritual of Satan in
elite circles as we are so seeing in the
Epstein files as well as temples of
Satan.
The occult operates on the principle of
as is, I mean sorry, as above so below.
balancing opposites, fusing male and
female with the intention of eventually
erasing them. So, no genders whatsoever
and no limits on who to have sex with.
In Cabala and ceremonial magic,
androgyny, blending of male and female,
or not really looking like one or the
other, gender is divine. The Baffomet
figure itself literally has both breasts
and male organs. Just in case you
weren't aware, this isn't love. It's
Luciferian doctrine coming into the
church, redefining God's design, and
then calling it sacred.
God created male and female distinction
specifically in Genesis 1 27.
He calls this lifestyle vile affections
in Romans 1:26-28.
And in Matthew 19:4-6,
Jesus reaffirms marriage is between a
man and a woman.
The Bible Bible verse below says they
invert holiness, calling evil good and
good evil.
Wow. So true. In Isaiah 5 20, this is
alchemal rebellion turned divine turning
divine order into chaos then rep sorry
then presenting it as progress.
All right we have next immediate heaven
or hell doctrines.
You will see that in churches like these
they teach you you go to heaven the
moment you die and that hell is eternal
torment.
Sorcery and witchcraft always involves
contacting the dead, invoking spirits,
or believing souls exist in disembodied
form. Keep that in mind.
In Babylon, Egypt, Greece, and Rome,
they believed immortal souls traveled to
heaven, hell, or became gods.
The truth is this belief comes from
Plato and Egypt, not the Bible. The
truth is the dead sleep until
resurrection. According
to the Bible, Ecclesiastes 95-6,
it says, "The dead know nothing. His
thoughts perish."
Acts 2 through3
2 verse 34 says, "David is not ascended
into the heavens."
Where does he go? Well, the Bible says
clearly in John 11-14,
the dead are asleep and will rise at the
resurrection. 1 Thessalonians 4:16.
This teaching of going straight to
heaven is a foundational belief in every
occult religion and opens the door to
praying to saints, ghosts, necromancy,
and ancestral veneration, which is
sorcery and idolatry. believing in
intermediate phases of existence with
those from the afterlife that can move,
talk and communicate with us and
interacting with them and those so
so-called spirits is forbidden by the
Bible.
Then there are three bonus points which
I have for you. These go a little bit
deeper.
Symbols. We'll go back to the symbols
again. In a church that has a cult
symbolism such as obelisks or steeples,
that's a phallic symbol. It's used in
sun worship. Sunbursts behind Jesus or
apostles heads behind crosses or pulpits
is really representative of the solar
deities. Triangles with eyes in them.
Triangles in general, eyes or trinity
knots equals the ancient trinities and
the eye of Horus.
IHS on tapestries, windows, tables. I've
explained that is Isis Horus set and
hexogs and pentagrams is actually the
star of Ramfan Raman mentioned in Amos 5
26. It's not David's star but in a cult
symbol.
Doves in circles. This one even shocked
me. Doves and circles is used in Roman
mystery cults to symbolize Venus and
mother goddesses.
labyrinth floors, runes and sigils
which are used for meditative pagan
walking rituals and invocations of
demons.
We have seen this several times in
churches,
Mikey and I, and
we saw runes like
this. We've seen these labyrinths which
are said to bring you to different
levels as you pray and walk through
them. I hope you see that star of of um
Moolok or Reman as it's called down in
the lower left corner there in the
stained glass window. Even that is not
pure.
The truth is these are Masonic and
further back than that the Masons are
getting it from the Egyptian and
Babylonian signs. They are intentionally
placed by those mixing mystery religion
with cre Christianity.
If they talk about secret brotherhoods,
I didn't know this and I didn't even
know that people talked about it, but we
were at a church and they said, "We are
so looking forward, this person's in the
hospital or something like that. They're
sick." But they were sure to to tell the
congregation that they're looking
forward to being a part of that um group
when they meet again. And it was a
secret society.
So if they talk about secret societies,
brotherhood, sisters and clubs or
orders, this is Freemasonry.
I have not spoken in secret, God says,
in a dark place of the earth. I said not
unto the seed of Jacob, seek ye me in
vain. I the Lord speak righteousness. I
declare things that are right. So this
is said in Isaiah 45:e 19.
They shall pollute my holy name.
It says in Ezekiel 23 38-39.
Can't we see that so much?
This is fully not of God because these
act all these symbols act as spiritual
contracts giving legal ground to
deception and demonic presence. Satan
worship and ideologies
you should know are being upheld in full
view before your face without them even
telling you that that is what they're
teaching or that they believe they're
showing you through symbols.
All right, their practices. A clue is
soaking aka meditation, spontaneous
dance, painting, visions, contemplative
prayer, breathing techniques, yoga,
mantras, and incantations.
Soaking refers to lying down or sitting
in silence with soft music playing
supposedly to receive from God or be
given enlightenment or more knowledge.
But unlike prayer or study of the word,
it involves passively emptying the mind,
inviting visions or emotional
experiences to come, making it nearly
identical to eastern meditation and
mystic cha channeling of demons aka
spirits. Rather than drawing near
through scripture, it opens the door to
spiritual deception by seeking
experience without discernment.
Other practices as these use substances
to enter other states of consciousness.
Similarly, for enlightenment from God or
consumption in a ritual as the pagans
do, they use wine perhaps drinking
marijuana, hiawasa, mushrooms, etc.
I might add to this that
they um
oh yes soaking. So we know that even
grave soaking I I hope I'm saying that
correctly but that the bethl and hill
songong and a lot of the the people who
are creating the music that is so
demonic also um that brings in the
emotional highs and makes people ride
that emotional way where they don't even
know they're not communicating with God
but they go home with a good feeling
that is completely deceptive
is using they're using grave soaking
from
trying to gather
um inspiration from dead people on the
graves and laying there to soak it up to
create these songs, the rhythms, the
lyrics, everything.
Okay, so all of these things mirror
Hindu meditation, new age visualization,
and Wiccan creative rituals. The Bible
says in Matthew 6:7, "Vain repetitions
as the heathens do." This is why it's
not of God. These methods attempt to
generate spiritual experiences without
repentance, truth, or obedience, and is
opening doors to Satan
and his demons.
The third one which is a bonus and I
know many people might not know or not
like hearing about is the 501c3 status
which churches are registered under.
Churches registers as this are
incorporated under the beast system. Why
do I say this? Well, first let's get
into how you would know this. The clue
is that churches won't preach against
certain things, certain sins, politics,
or cultural issues.
And this is because why do I say that
it's the B system? Well,
the IRS has to okay everything that you
are doing. And the IRS is not really
governed necessarily by the US. Again,
it's this hand inhand connection between
the US and all of ecumenicism.
So, no church as you see there's s
several symbols out there. The ones that
I do know I can't really read fully is a
Saddleback Church, um, Harvest and the
Adventist Church. They are all 501c3s.
They've all been incorporated into this
and so they've sold out. I do know this.
And the 501c3 is a government leash. It
changes a church into a state approved
religious corporation.
controlling what is said to be in
keeping with what is politically
acceptable during its time and season
that they want to promote it.
This allows the government to slowly
shape religion into a harmless
controlled arm of their system.
In Mark 12 verse1 17 it says render to
Caesar what is Caesars's and to God what
is God's.
Let me clarify
why it's specifically not godly is
because a church should be under
Christ's headship, not the IRS or the
government's regulation.
Most pastors are now muzzled agents of
religious unity.
Their sermons are censored, their speech
restricted, and their allegiance subtly
shifted from Christ to compliance,
usually without the congregation
knowing. Many don't even realize that by
operating under a 501c3,
they've signed spiritual gag orders, if
you will, that prevent them from calling
out sin, warning of judgment to come, or
exposing the beast system rising around
them. This is by design.
All right? So, I want to take this time
to make you guys aware of all of this.
But if you recognize these things in
your church, any of these, I hope that
you feel an urgency for repentance.
Leave that church and these sinful
beliefs and practices behind.
God is coming soon. And the true remnant
is not hiding in mega buildings or
churches
or denominations, I will add,
but is being called out, refined, and
made ready. They are standing up even if
they have to do it alone in Christ and
leaving false worship behind.
Jesus said, "Take heed that no man
deceive you." in Matthew 24:4.
That is exactly why I want to do this
show.
So, it is time to test the spirits,
examine everything by the word, and flee
from all forms of spiritual idolatry,
even within our churches.
Be holy and perfect and
be refined by God. He wants you to be
righteous.
Be righteous.
That is what I have for you guys. It's a
powerful message. It is something, like
I said, I've been aware of many of these
things for so long. And finally, the
church, all the churches in the world
might be ready to finally hear it. So,
thank you guys. And happy Sabbath. And I
hope this blesses you and truly convicts
you and helps you,
each of us, to get our lives together
because God wants us to be his people.
All right. Thank you guys. If you want
to get merchandise, you can go on
candidruth.org. We have a link there for
the shop.
And here are our links. If you would be
so moved, um, we appreciate it you guys.
It's a blessing to have you support our
channel in any of these ways and payment
methods. Those are the links for it. Um,
again, thank you guys so much for tuning
in and have a good night. Bye-bye.